-Thank you.
Thank you so much.
New York City,
you guys doing well?
[ Cheers ]
Awesome!
I'm doing very well.
I have a girlfriend
and she is amazing,
but I'm trying to hold onto her
and I'm nervous for two reasons.
First, because I look like
the guy in a romcom
who gets left at the altar.
It doesn't end well for this
guy,
mother's always saying stuff
like, "Catherine, I don't care
if he cheats on you,
Colton comes from
a good family."
Like that kind of...
This is a bottle of pills.
And second, second reason she
can do better.
She's kind of overqualified.
Like, she used to be a
professional athlete,
which is hilarious because I'm
not good at sports.
I played middle school football
in college.
I'm just not a,
not a coordinated person.
I look like I do sports, though.
But I look like
I exclusively do sports
that most people can't afford.
[ Laughter ]
Like I made varsity
in rhino hunting or something.
I look like if you said
racquetball and squash
are the same three times,
I would appear and be like,
"Well, technically..."
my whole vibe.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
My girlfriend swam though.
She was a professional swimmer.
She was very good.
She was a multi-time
national champion,
she was world ranked
and she's retired now
and adjusting to life on land,
but you can still tell
she was a swimmer
because she's very tall,
very muscular,
but still very feminine,
so like skinny waist,
broad child-bearing shoulders.
I feel safe in her arms.
And it's, uh, it's different.
It's different dating a girl
who's close to my size.
There's like a lot of little
things I miss out on,
like a thing a lot of straight
guys like to do is
you give your girlfriend
your shirt to sleep in.
And it fits her very baggy
and billowy
and that makes you feel very
manly and protective.
And when my girlfriend
puts on my shirt,
it's like, "Oh, that's how that
should fit. Yeah, that's..."
[ Laughter ]
Mwah! Mm.
Way better. Yeah.
Yeah, you just give it back to
me when you grow out of it.
And here's my lunch money,
like it's --
[ Speaks gibberish ]
And she swam her whole life,
so every guy she dated before me
was a swimmer.
Like, the last guy she went out
with was very fast.
He was a 50 freestyle,
100 freestyle specialist
with a little bit
of 100 butterfly.
He went to collegiate nationals,
he had Olympic Trials cuts.
I only googled him
for a few hours,
but a very,
very talented athlete
from what I could sleuth up.
And fun fact about this guy,
he is 6'7".
My girlfriend's ex-boyfriend
is 6'7".
And that used to mess
with my self-esteem
but the really cool part
about that is
that we can just sleep
in his old shirts.
It's great.
[ Laughter ]
Very spacious.
Lot of room.
And I didn't realize until we
started dating,
tall women,
it's kind of unfair for them.
Like, our culture has this weird
way of making them feel bad
about their bodies,
but it's always very subtle.
Like a great example is my
girlfriend's feet are a size 11.
But women shoe si--
already laughing all right.
[ Laughter ]
Ha, ha! We-- no.
Shoe store typically don't carry
above size 10,
so she has to buy all of her
shoes online,
on a website called --
how mean is this --
amazon.com,
like that's not nice.
Very rude.
And we live together.
We actually moved in after
dating for less than one year.
And people think that was
a little fast,
but we were both just
so in love,
with saving $900 a month,
ah, it's so great.
We live in Fort Greene,
which is one of those trendy
Brooklyn neighborhoods.
It's the kind of place where
gender is a spectrum
but cold brew and iced coffee
are very different actually.
It's like that.
[ Laughter ]
So, including my girlfriend,
I have three roommates.
And our apartment
is a perfect example
of what's happened to Brooklyn.
So I work in entertainment,
they work in
marketing, tech,
and real estate.
If you haven't read Revelations,
that is the four horsemen.
Like this is true,
if we stand in a diamond,
put our hands together,
and chant
an Apple store opens.
It just rumbles through
the ground.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Our entire block is powered by
soul cycle classes.
Switched over the grid.
All right.
And I like doing stuff
with my roommates.
A couple weeks ago,
it was me, my girlfriend Laura,
my roommate Harry,
and his boyfriend.
And we were watching "Queer Eye"
on Netflix.
And I agree, it's a great show.
And I expressed that to the
group.
I said, "I really enjoy this
show because not only
is it very entertaining,
it's also very progressive."
And my girlfriend said,
"No, no it's not."
I said, "What?"
She says, "Yeah.
This is just men
taking the advice
that women have been giving them
for years,
they only listen
when they hear it from a man."
And I was like, "No, no.
I don't agree with that.
I don't think that's true."
And then Harry jumps in.
He says, "Actually, Matthew,
studies show men are more likely
to dismiss ideas when they hear
them from women."
And I said, "Harry, that is a
great point, wow.
Thank you, Herald."
I was blind but now I see.
Hey, thank you so much.
-Hey.
Well done, pal.
Matthew Broussard!
[ Cheers and applause ]
His comedy album is available
now on iTunes.